it is believed generally in india
that when a person sets out on the way
of liberation
his first problem is to become free from
his past
karma the popular theory of karma the
word that literally means
action or doing in sanskrit so that when
we say that something that happens to
you is your karma
it's like saying in english it's your
own doing
but in in popular indian
belief karma is a sort of built-in
moral law or a law of retribution
such that all the bad things you do and
all the good things you do
have consequences which you have to
inherit
and so long as karmic energy remains
stored up
you have to work it out and what the
sage endeavors to do
is a kind of action which in sanskrit is
called nishkama
karma nishkama means without
passion or without attachment karma
action
and so whether he whatever action he
does
he renounces the fruits of the action
so that he acts in a way that doesn't
generate
future karma because future karma
continues you
in the wheel of becoming sangsara
the round and keeps you being
reincarnated
now then in that case when the time
comes that you start
to get out of the chain of karma
all the creditors that you have start
presenting themselves for payment
in other words a person who begins say
to study yoga is felt that he will
suddenly get sick
or that his children will die or that
he'll lose his money or all sorts of
catastrophes will occur
because the karmic debt
is being cleared up and
it there's in no hurry to be cleared up
if you're just living along like anybody
but if you embark on the spiritual life
a certain hurry occurs
and therefore since this is known
uh it's rather discouraging to start
these things
the christian way of saying the same
thing
is that if you plan to be to change your
life
shall we say to turn over a new leaf you
mustn't let the devil know
because he will oppose you with all his
might
if he suddenly discovers that you're
going to escape from his power
so for example if you have a bad habit
say you drink too much
and you make a new year's resolution
that during this coming year you'll stop
drinking
that's a very very dangerous thing to do
because the devil will immediately know
about it
and what will happen will be this he
will confront you with the prospect of
365 drinkless days
and that will be awful you know just
overwhelming
and you won't be able to make much more
than three days on the wagon
so in that case you compromise with the
devil and say
just today i'm not going to drink you
see but tomorrow may be you know we'll
go back
then when tomorrow comes you say oh just
another day let's try
that's all and the next day you say oh
one more day won't make
much difference so you only do it for
the moment and you don't let the devil
know that you have a secret intention
of going on day after day after day
after day
uh but of course
there's something still better than that
and that is not to let the devil know
anything
and that means of course not to let
yourself know
one of the many meanings of that saying
let not your left hand know what your
right hand doeth is just this
and that was why in uh zen discipline
uh a great deal of it centers around
acting without premeditation
as those of you know who read herregle's
book zen in the art of archery
it was necessary to release the
bowstring without first
saying now there's a wonderful story you
may also have read by a german writer
von kleist
about her a boxing match with a bear
the man can never defeat this bear
because the bear always knows
his plans in advance
and is ready to deal with any situation
the only way to get through to the bear
would be to hit the bear without having
first intended to do so
that would catch him and so this
is one of the great great problems in
the spiritual life or whatever you want
to call it
is to be able to have intention and act
simultaneous by this means you escape
karma
and you escape the devil